Donald Trump has sued Hillary Clinton in
a very strange sprawling lawsuit that
doesn't make any sense Reuters is
reporting Trump sues Hillary over 2016
Russian collusion allegations
Donald Trump on Thursday sued his rival
in the 2016 election Hillary Clinton and
several other Democrats alleging they
tried to rig that election by tying his
campaign to Russia now what's funny
about this is this is all crazy and
we'll go through it
the Russia stuff
really was after Trump had won
so how could you rig an elect again it's
like do you not understand time how do
you rig the 2016 election by talking
about Russia in 2017. doesn't really
make sense anyway the lawsuit covers a
long list of grievances
um and comes As Trump continues to
falsely claim he actually won in 2020.
acting in this is from the lawsuit
acting in concert the defendants
maliciously conspired to weave a false
narrative that their Republican opponent
Trump was colluding with a hostile
foreign sovereignty
the lawsuit alleges racketeering and a
conspiracy to commit injurious falsehood
a Clinton representative didn't respond
the lawsuit wants compensatory and
punitive damages Trump said he was quote
forced to incur expenses and an amount
to be determined at trial but known to
be in excess of 24 million dollars and
continuing to accrue in the form of
Defense cost legal fees and related
expenses do you accrue legal fees if you
don't pay them I guess sort of but Trump
often doesn't pay his uh his lawyers
another article about this Donald Trump
sues Hillary Clinton and allies over
Russia claims sprawling lawsuit accuses
a large cast of racketeering conspiracy
over allegations that Trump was in
Putin's pocket in 2016. so listen as
usual you know how we've talked about
this uh unfortunate reality or
phenomenon where the right says Hey the
left is doing this and it's actually
they who are doing it
the left is going to rig the election
actually you tried to but fortunately
you failed the left can't be trusted
with classified and secret and sensitive
information actually it was you flushing
documents down the toilet taking them to
Mar-A-Lago spilling secrets to a Russian
spy recruiter in the Oval Office and on
and on and on and uh likewise here the
Wright loves to say the left is
constantly suing everybody frivolous
lawsuits we've got to deal with it tort
reform and all this stuff
isn't it time for a judge to start
holding the lawyers accountable who file
these trash lawsuits because they are
absurd and you can be sure I mean put
take a step back
everything else aside you can be sure
this lawsuit won't go anywhere because
if it did
the defendants would have the ability to
carry out Discovery and Discovery could
include up to and including deposing
Donald Trump okay maybe Trump can raise
money off of this in the short term from
his low information followers maybe he
can convince them like he convinced so
many of them donate to me and I'll fund
recounts and we'll flip this election
and it was a lie and many of them gave
him money maybe Trump can similarly tell
them give me money so that we can sue
Hillary
but in the long term
this is going nowhere because Trump and
his lawyers know it would be a disaster
if they were subjected to Discovery
um and that's basically it this will
almost certainly be dropped soon and uh
it is another one of these instances of
do as I say not as I do and I'll
whatever I do by definition is right
because I'm doing it and everybody else
is lying to you and I'm telling you the
truth except I lie all the time that's
basically the bottom line here I expect
this to go absolutely nowhere
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for Quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release is
no exception it's the Argo automatic it
spotlights everything I love about
vincero I got the Argo automatic in
Frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but I really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out I love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face I really
love all of their watches and I own a
bunch but the Argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero Collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below